Bonjour!
C'est Cyprien,
et si il y bien un truc qui m...
Ah oui !
J'ai mis un cadre.
C'est mon petit coté bling bling,
de la télévision, tu vois?
Dans la vie, il y a des choix à faire,
des choix de différentes importances
et je n'ai jamais compris pourquoi le choix
le plus déterminant de toute ta vie, EVER,
tu dois le prendre quand t'es gamin.
Non.
Alors, tu veux faire quoi après le collège, gamin?
Euh, au début, je voulais faire un bac S,
mais, je crois que je vais faire un bac L, en fait,
parce que j'aime bien le francais.
Tu veux faire un bac L.
Ok ! ok ! D'accord !
Pas de problèmes. Tu..
tu vas vite comprendre
pourquoi y'a deux L, dans "pôle emploi".
Il est mignon !
Désolé, mais à 15 ans tu sais pas c'que tu veux faire de ta vie hein !
Tu penses qu'à jouer à Pokemon,
ou... brûler des voitures !
Et à côté de ça,  t'as des choix qui n'ont aucune importance.
Des choix nuls quoi !
Mais qui te perturbent autant, voire plus,
que les choix les plus importants de toute ta vie.
Je pense notamment...à l'ascenseur qui veut pas descendre.
"Il est long cet ascenseur."
"Bon, j'vais prendre l'escalier."
"Ah, peut-être que l'ascenseur va arriver dès que j'vais prendre l'escalier !"
''En même temps ça fait 5 minutes que j'attends,''
"ça m'aurait pris dix secondes en montant les marches là !"
''C'est con d'prendre l'escalier après tout le temps que j'ai attendu.''
''Je fais quoi, je fais quoi, je, merde, je...''
''Bon, l'escalier.''
Et en fait, j'ai réfléchi.
Ça m'arrive une fois par mois,
tu peux classer les choix en 2 catégories :
D'abord, t'as le choix de la sécurité,
le choix que tu fais tout le temps,
no problem.
Hey chéri, regarde, j'ai acheté un nouveau t-shirt.
Encore un t-shirt noir,
mais tu changes jamais, j'en ai marre,
j'te quitte.
Et puis, t'as le choix du changement,
du risque où tu te fais un petit kiffe, quoi?
Hey chéri, regarde, j'ai acheté un nouveau t-shirt.
J'te quitte.
Et puis, au bout d'un moment, t'arrêtes de te faire des kiffes, plus jamais,
tu ne fais que des choix raisonnables,
tu te conditionnes à la société,
tu deviens normal.
''Qu'est-ce que je vais manger aujourd'hui?''
''Tiens, de la salade et une tomate. Cool.''
''J'ai même un yaourt pour le dessert.''
Alors qu'au fond de toi, ...
''Des desserts, je vais manger que des desserts,''
''toute ma vie, et des gâteaux aussi,''
''des gâteaux, et des desserts, pis des gâteaux, pis des desserts.''
Au final, pour faire, pour faire des choix dans la vie,
pour prendre des décisions importantes,
il suffit d'une seule chose :
de la détermination.
Ce dont je n'ai absolument pas.
''Bon, c'est décidé, je me mets au ménage.''
''Ah, une manette.''
HODOKEN!!
Je sais pas comment font les autres, hein.
Au fait, j'ai une page Facebook finalement.
HODOKEN!!
T'es pas obligé de cliquer sur j'aime sur ma page facebook
Mais si tu le fais pas, je te pète ta gueule.